[Music]
stranded on an alien planet no tardis no
plan
let's get to work
[Music]
doctor who series 11 continues with
episode
2 the ghost monument
let's kind of jump to the end and then
work our way back to it
i like this a lot i like it notably
better than i did with the woman who
fell to earth
not that i thought that that was a bad
episode but having now watched it a few
more times after my initial viewing
it's just kind of fine i've seen more
than a few people call
that episode torchwood-esque i'm not
sure it is in terms of the overall
episode but it certainly does feel more
akin to torchwood in its depiction of
earth and you know that community the
way it depicted sheffield felt
kind of on par with what you would
expected in torchwood especially weird
moments like that friggin
salad guy i don't know what was going on
with that but
this while i'm not gonna say this
feels more like doctor who this does not
feel like
not doctor who if that makes sense it's
very obvious that they are
trying a lot of new things in terms of
the presentation certainly the visual
look of it there's a lot more
um dynamic things going on here there's
a lot of handheld camera work which is
not automatically
a better way to do it but doctor who
with a couple of episode exceptions
scattered across its run modern era
doctor who had kind of fallen into a
very
standard shooting format and they seem
to be looking to shake that
up here they're getting more stylized
with the shooting which i think is
overall a perfectly fine thing to try
out and whereas
last episode that ended up feeling like
torchwood this
while not necessarily necessarily
automatically feeling more like doctor
who
doesn't feel specifically like another
show that i can name or at least
i can't for my own point of reference so
the feel of it is more on par jody
whitaker i'm still not sure that i've
had
the moment that i want to have from her
but i have had some i have had some good
moments with her now and she's
like i like her better that and again i
didn't dislike her last episode i'm just
she's
she's growing on me more i think the
moment that i really did enjoy was
that she's snapping at this guy
basically trying to tell him look
i know how we can land your ship and if
you don't let me do it we're all gonna
die and jazz is behind us like
wait what oh hi ass didn't realize you
were there everything's gonna be fine
and then turns back and starts yelling
at the guy again
loved that and that sort of bounced back
and forth that balance between her
desire to keep
everybody okay yet her need to get in
there and
get control and make sure that that
actually ends up being the case
it's kind of an interesting balance i've
seen some people label her
already and this is two episodes in so
it's a little early for me
but i've seen some people label her the
empathetic doctor
which she might end up being i'm gonna
keep an eye on it kind of with that in
mind
um because that's an approach that if
i'd known going in i would have been
very cautious of because the doctor
being
overly empathetic is that's i'm not
gonna say he's never
empathetic but that's not usually an
inherent trait he cares about people but
he doesn't usually
get them you know what i mean but um
that if that's the angle they're going
for so far it's certainly working for me
i also like kind of watching her
annoyance at
wanting just wanting some answers and in
some instances talking to people that
you know has them but they're not going
to tell her and just her frustration
with that um you know just just knowing
that there's information that's
available that she doesn't have
and again that's kind of writing a fine
line because it could have come across
and annoyed at not knowing which again
would have not been very doctors because
the doctor kind of gets excited when
when they don't know something i think
what i've referred to the doctor now in
a more global sense i'll i might start
using they
i don't know i just kind of did it there
i'm figuring this out as i go in any
case
um you know traditionally the doctor
tends to get very excited
not knowing something whereas here the
doctor doesn't quite get annoyed at not
knowing but she does get annoyed knowing
that she's
lacking information she could probably
deal with the fact that she doesn't know
but knowing that there are
tidbits that she is not privy to that
frustrated her and i liked watching that
uh that played out pretty well
the companions are working pretty well i
still
am of the opinion that it's a little
crowded that
three is too many and if i it of the
three currently here if i were to point
at a
dead weight seems like too harsh a word
but if i were to point out the one who's
not pulling their weight right now it
would be yaz
with ryan and graham i really am
enjoying them particularly for that for
their dynamic and that really does feel
like something that we can
watch develop and watch their
relationship um
as they come to better terms with each
other over the course of the series that
really feels like there's room for
growth
there um and because you get a good
sense of where it is you get a good
sense of where
a better place for it to be and i like
their dynamic overall
especially when it came to talking about
um gran's wife
uh ryan's grandmother because you know
ryan is young enough to think that he's
got to figure out and
just decide i don't want to talk about
this and graham is old enough to know
that no you kind of have to talk about
it whether you want to or not and i'm
enjoying their dynamic as a whole yaz is
not devoid of decent moments but
comparatively she's had way less so far
like she really only had one moment that
i really kind of enjoyed which was
she actually sort of paused and asked
one of these uh
people in this intergalactic
race you know about her planet where she
was from
and that i think that was the one where
they felt like okay that that feels like
i guess almost kind of pulling in her
policing like you know sit them down
talk them out
you know get get on their side
you know convince them you're not their
enemy talk them down
and she she has that moment but it is
just a moment and certainly compared to
how many moments i
felt that ryan and graham had it's not
nearly as much
as far as the overall setup of this
episode it's not
um like super unique or original it's
just really well assembled
um so if again if i were compared to the
first episode the first episode wasn't
particularly unique either and was
decently assembled this one is not
especially unique on paper
but is just put together much better i
think both from writing
and directing avenues so
we've got you know basically you know
the
the great race or i don't know i don't
watch reality
tv shows or whatever whatever whatever
that is
basically in space and there's only two
left and down you know trying to get
this prize
they're on this planet everything can
possibly kill them
and i like the the difference between
you know someone who
is doing this because well
you can't trust anybody and this is his
way of becoming truly self-sufficient
and the other one doing it because
i if i get this prize i can help the
people i love
and i surprisingly liked the the
hologram of the guy who's running the
thing
i liked him a lot actually for even the
little tiny bits that we get him
like i really loved at the end where the
two the two of the i mean spoilers i am
going to talk about the end and talk
about all this like
if you're watching this review and not
like okay
all right i'll hold off on that for a
second so before i get into spoilers
overall
very good um oh before i have to get
into things that are flat out spoilers
uh opening credits i love them
holy cow they're gorgeous i love the new
orchestration on the
theme as well it's really cool what i
really like about the
the the look actually because having uh
you know been working on getting back
through classic that whole
sort of folding in and out thing it's
really super reminiscent of
old old doctor who
intros like first and second doctor sort
of
look like rorschach looking thing i
really
really dig that i think it's gorgeous i
mean i'm i'm not gonna be like best one
ever but i'd
definitely one of the best ones of the
modern era certainly i i just
it it still feels like doctor who but it
is distinctly different i
dig it a lot um
and the other stuff i'll consider that
spoilerish so
yeah i like this a lot this was uh for
me a notable step up
from the previous episode uh which was
already
decent so this this gets me
much more excited for what's going to
come next so getting into things that do
count as spoilers where was it
what was i going to say oh so there was
the thing
that i really liked at the end where
after the the two people win the race
and they're like oh and get these guys
off this plane too and the guys just
like
no and you know boom and they're gone i
just loved his attitude like
look i'll i'll help you out a little bit
but not like not that much i liked how i
liked that
um it made him you know an antagonistic
figure without making
him a complete you know villain
um and i i like the new tardis interior
as well i'm not sure i
completely love the lighting on it i i
feel like it's lit
a little dark i don't know
except i don't know the the tardis for
most of new
i think really except for matt smith's
first
tardis interior has tended to be on the
darker side maybe it's the fact that
it's the warmer colors i think i got
really used to
um like the dark lighting but with blues
and greens which is what we got with
the the version of the tardis that was
the
you know for matt smith's last series
and for all of capaldi's run
so maybe it's the combination of it
being dark and also the shift from
cooler to warmer colors
again not bad um and i do like the
design i think the design is very cool i
kind of like that they've got a crystal
thing running
between you know the doctor's sonic
with the you know the visible crystal on
the end of it now the interior
of the tardis i have no doubt um and i'm
gonna i'm gonna
make it a head cannon thing at least for
me that the tardis like picked up on the
design of the sonic screwdriver was like
okay
i can work with that and gave us what we
got
um we didn't get and i suspect we
probably never will
an actual reason why the doctor
was dumped out of the tardis because
i'm gonna fall back on what i've kind of
always assumed it did it so that
it could set up an opening of the new
series where the doctor doesn't have the
tardis
you know just for the same reason it
blew up
for no reason you know it was a it was a
meta reason it wasn't a narrative reason
it was a meta reason of we want an
excuse to redesign it
which is stupid because they've
redesigned it without blowing it up
before anyway the
transition for the matt smith one i just
talked about they didn't blow it up
before they did that
and you know we want her to be without
the tardis so we'll just have a dumper i
suspect there is not actually a
narrative justification for that which
is a little bit frustrating because it
re
it does read very much as a
deliberateness
thing with the tardis feeling like it
was dumping her and
it's kind of like if there's not going
to be an explanation for what that was i
really would have rather
the that they hadn't had it you know
because it just sort of i don't know it
stands out now as a weird moment in
hindsight but i don't know maybe it'll
be dealt with later oh there's
there is one other thing that has the
potential to annoy me we'll see
one of the things that i liked in the
lead-up to this
new series was that it was said that
they weren't going to do
a series arc not this series at the very
least
except i saw the planting of two
things that really feel like
mystery box elements things that are
gonna crop up
repeatedly across the series and that
was
tying in the sort of weapons development
planet in with
the alien that um tim shaw
was from the previous episode which if
they're not going to do something more
with that
that's a weird connection to make
because he wasn't that intimidating and
as one guy he didn't
feel like he represented a society that
we should be afraid of so i have to
assume that his race is going to come
back
so that is becoming a through line then
the other thing is when the the sort of
cloths that could wrap around people's
heads to suffocate them which was
actually well planted by the way i did
notice the um
the cameras kept lingering on these
things but they looked so much like
shredding scraps or clothes i assumed
that that was going to be revealed to be
you know the all that was left of
of people who'd been here before to
actually have those turn out to be
weapons that was kind of cool and it was
seeded or
early on you know as a visual element
but when they're
sort of speaking which is a little bit
weird and contrived in and of itself
especially because it feels like it may
only have been done to plant this whole
idea of
the timeless child we can see things
about you that you don't even want to
acknowledge and i'm
sitting here going this really really
really
really sounds and feels like mystery box
planting
and uh i've i've expressed my
frustration and my annoyance in my just
being sick
of the mystery box as a way of doing a
series arc
in the past and if they end up doing it
this series after
you know indications were that they
weren't
you know then all the leave like no no
we're not going to do that this series
that's going to annoy me
same reason i'm going to get annoyed if
the daleks turn up after we've been told
oh no no there aren't going to be daleks
this series
well i i i appreciate
wanting to give fans a surprise i
appreciate
keeping things you know close to the
best what i don't appreciate is being
flat out lied to
i i am i'm sorry i'm always going to be
resentful of that because
then you know it leaves you going oh but
it's really this see we were so clever
we filtered no you didn't fool me you
lied to me
there's a difference you you you showed
me you did
for me what that what that guy's mother
did for him
you are teaching me not to trust you um
so man i should tie that in nicely i'm
i'm
more proud of myself for that than i
should be but
that that again that may only be well
that's going to be one of two um
complaints
about this episode because either those
things
are seeding series long stuff in which
case i'm going to resent the series
overall because
we were told this wasn't going to go on
and now it's going on and
i was ready to be done with this kind of
stuff at the very least for one series
or alternately this isn't
building for siri stuff you know the
timeless child doesn't mean anything and
the fact that this was that same race
doesn't matter in which case
why would you make that connection it
didn't add anything to this story which
is otherwise a good solid strong story
and i really liked finding out that the
ghost monument was the tardis
i don't know why i didn't call that in
advance i was actually trying to figure
out i wonder how they're
at the end of this how are they going to
get to the tardis but have it just be
it like i feel like they revealed that
at just the right moment um where if
they'd waited much longer i might have
i might have come to that conclusion on
my own but they did that reveal i'm like
oh
nice so again overall despite some
gripes and nitpicks and concerns
um on my part i really like this episode
i liked it a lot
and i'm hoping that this is the pace
that
that we can keep i feel like the whole
thing just felt better
once it got off earth which inherently
makes me slightly nervous for the next
episode knowing it's a historical
set episode on earth because earth is a
setting where i tend to not enjoy the
doctors at least in modern era nearly as
much
and i really
tend to not like the historical set
episodes it's a the rare exception that
i do
oh the venusian aikido's back that was a
nice touch too
um yeah but we'll
we'll see but dealing with this episode
as a self-contained episode it's good
it's quite good i liked it quite a bit
um you know there are things that i'm
going to keep an eye on for
for down the line in terms of some of
these characters and some of these plot
things which may or may not come back
and i'll have my opinions on those as we
go along but i think
i will wrap it up there i probably
forgot one or two things that i meant to
mention
and didn't but what can you do um so
that'll wrap it up folks the ghost
monument what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts were
drop something down the comments let's
talk about it there's a whole bunch of
stuff
that you can do because there's buttons
and there's links including a link to my
patreon if you feel like supporting me
in that fashion
if you don't though don't sweat it
there's other stuff you can check out
and in any case
folks you're the council and i just run
the meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you